la dernière étape du Tour de France 2023
partira depuis les Yvelines ce dimanche
23 juillet et ce sera une grande
première il partira depuis le vélodrome
national au programme un départ de la
caravane publicitaire à 14h30 depuis
l'avenue du centre de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux avant de passer
devant l'ensemble sportive 15 heures
présentation des coureurs sur l'ère
centrale du vélo Drôme national
attention les réservations sont
obligatoires pour assister à l'événement
vous pouvez les réserver sur le site
officiel du Vélodrome le départ fictif
de cette étape de 115,1 km sera quant à
lui donner à 16h30 sur le parvis du
Vélodrome devant plusieurs milliers de
spectateurs Poga Yonas Wingard et le
reste du peloton passeront devant les
futurs sites olympiques ziminois comme
le Stadium de BMX la colline Delancourt
encore le golf national avant de partir
dans le reste des Yvelines une course
que les spectateurs du Vélodrome
national pourront suivre sur les écrans
géants installés à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur côté circulation ça risque
d'être très compliqué à dans les
Yvelines le peloton passera par la D12
de Bois-d'Arcy par Fontenay-le-Fleury la
D11 des Clayes-sous-Bois par plaisir
avant de redescendre direction Élancourt
et la commanderie des Templiers les
cyclistes passeront par la verrière au
niveau du bois de l'étang avant de
revenir à Montigny-le-Bretonneux par la
D36 direction Voisins-le-Bretonneux puis
Guyancourt les coureurs traversent son
verset en passant par l'avenue de Paris
devant le château avant de quitter les
Yvelines par Viroflay vers 17h30
direction les Champs-Élysées pendant une
grosseur environ les milliers divinois
pourront voir 700 dixième édition du
Tour de France tout est prêt pour
accueillir l'événement maintenant place
au spectacle